hey Matt there's another we release
coming our way and that's Devil May Cry
4 special edition you actually just got
to play it so can you tell me what the
new things are in this game so what they
added is three new characters you got
Virgil who's Dante's twin brother lady
who fans will recognize from Devil May
Cry 3 and Trish who is like classic
character from the first Devil May Cry
and what they've actually done is you
can play these characters in the in the
old levels right so Virgil you can play
through the entire campaign as just
Virgil but with Lady and Trish how does
that work exactly the same as Nero and
Dante's campaign so you'll basically
start the game as lady and then the
second half you'll come in this Trish
okay and unfortunately we're only able
to capture gameplay of Virgil so that's
what we're seeing right now can you tell
me how he actually plays it looks like
you got to be a little bit more
methodical with him right yeah when fans
will start playing him they'll recognize
that you yes printer stall the same
movesets that he had from Dellen
Chrysler Virgil in the way that he plays
is that he now is a concentration gauge
which is a gauge that fills up over time
as you bite and what it does is that it
gives you increased attack power and
range for each consecutive level that it
goes up yes so you can't like just jump
around like crazy and you can't miss
attacks and you kind of get hit
otherwise your meter goes down is that
right yeah you can't be crazy about
things with Virgil you really have to be
calm and collected kind of like Virgil
in a way no unfortunately we can't show
any of this footage with Lady and Trish
but Lady seems like she's a much more
focused on firearms naira yeah she's
totally built on ranged attacks she does
have some melee stuff but she's it's
extremely slow and what was Trisha like
well Trish is really similar to Dante
but with her kind of own unique twist on
things so she has a very similar
equipment set but she doesn't have sort
of the kinds of attacks that kind of
lunch afforded enemies like you know
what Dante's classic stinger move so as
a double McCoy fan I mean you played the
developer Clark for quite a few times
already do you feel there's enough here
to sort of get bands back into the game
oh definitely any hardcore fan will have
a lot to kind of sink their teeth in
with
this with all the new content because
there is a lot of new combos that really
kind of go through at this one because
every carrot has a lot of different
variations but for gamers who kind of
criticized the the campaign to make
right the original Democrat for they
won't really find anything too different
for this one from what they told us
basically you know there's gonna be a
couple of new cutscenes basically sort
of bookending the the Virgil campaign
and a lady Trish campaign but the actual
level design themselves has actually
changed that much so we're able to
accommodate those characters in the new
level and there were a few other things
there that you know weren't able to show
but you know there was legendary Dark
Knight mode which is basically just it
seems crazy mehoudar with a lots of
enemies thrown on the screen at once and
I'll guess we'll see how the whole thing
actually works out when the game
releases in the summer 2015
you